Magnus Carlson confirmed that he will
not be playing in the upcoming
candidates a tournament that decides the
Challenger for the world championship in
an interview with chess.com here's what
he said yeah I'm I'm not playing the
candidates don't worry about that fiday
the governing body of Chess recently
shared what they called a complete
lineup for the 2024 candidates which
happened to include Magnus last year
Magnus relinquished his world
championship title upset with the
current time control format and at the
2023 World Cup he earned an invite to
the upcoming candidates by winning the
event even back then and Magnus
expressed no intention of playing under
the current format there is absolutely
no chance so I think everybody should
just operate under the assumption that I
will not play the candidates and that
everybody else who's in the semi-final
is qualified for the candidates after
Fay shared the lineup Magnus responded
with an iteration of comedian Gro Marx's
famous quote I don't want to belong to
any club though will except me as a
member with Magnus officially opting out
the esteemed candidate spot will go to
World Cup semi-finalist ninat abasov